hello ladies and gentlemen my name is
ryan right welcome two reasons to see
where i'm going to provide you with
movie news in three minutes or less
frank miller is going to return to the
batman world with the Dark Knight saga
finally concluding I'm hoping this time
around it will feature more a frank
miller signature style a lot of internal
monologue a lot of prostitutes a lot of
gore and more prostitutes wyd rumor is
spreading that Xmen apocalypse and
wolverine 3 might be the end to that
little x-men universe they have going on
that Bryan Singer started are they gonna
reboot it probably yeah looks like
there's a strong frontrunner for the new
spider-man asa butterfield let's face it
depending on how you pronounce that
guy's name there is an anal joke in
there Kingsman the Secret Service is
getting a sequel why would or not it's
[ __ ] awesome looks like the 21 Jump
Street franchise is getting a female
spin-off and they're saying that
Channing Tatum and Jonah Hill will
continue their roles in a crossover with
men in black yeah that makes total sense
a lot more fun Batman uses come out
here's a photo of Ben Affleck as Batman
with a clear color picture where he
looks incredibly depressed he does not
look happy to be Batman and there's
rumors that the Joker might appear
Batman vs Superman and there's photos
that suggests that Batman will appear in
the Suicide Squad people are surprised
by this I don't know why because they're
clearly linked Daniel Bruhl confirms
he's going to be playing Baron Zemo in
Captain America Civil War this is huge
news for comic book fans in case you
guys don't know who that character is
well neither do i don't remember the
character's name now fresh off the box
office success of furious 7 james wan is
being I to direct Aquaman Furious 8 and
an adaptation of robotech in case you
guys don't know this james one is in
fact asian
but he has an Australian accent it
throwed me off the first time I saw that
avatar 5 may be a possibility sure we
haven't gone in two three and four yet
but apparently James camera has for
scripts ready to go people even care
about avatar anymore like right no one
does the other [ __ ] Smurfs all right
guys that's it for a movie news of the
week tune in next week we're i'll be
doing more movie news about movies that
have news out about them and you could
also catch my videos on latino review
com one of the best movie sites out
there Latinos rock but what's cooler
than when Latinos let other ethnicities
and on their site hey possum main I
can't help myself